muhammad akram is with his children in
their makeshift home it's a tent made
entirely of plastic sheets offering
little relief against the scorching heat
like others in this settlement akrom
feels he's been ignored and forgotten
about by the government during the
pandemic work has been hard to come by
and there's been little or no support
for those suffering from kovid 19 or to
get the vaccine
some officials came they asked around
took her names and left but no one has
come to vaccinate us yes they come often
to tell us to vacate that's it
even though vaccinations are free in
india accessing the jabs has been
virtually impossible for those living on
the margins of the more than 4 million
people who are homeless in urban india
at least 250 000 live on the streets of
new delhi a recent study found that more
than 80 percent of them had not been
vaccinated mainly because they were
unable to register online
ashok pandey is a social worker who grew
up on the streets
during the lockdown he was spreading
awareness about kobit 19 and is now
trying to encourage vaccinations
people are so scared because of the
rumors and the government hasn't done
enough to educate them about the vaccine
you may know about it from newspaper or
tv ads but they don't have these
facilities
most of them don't have phones and those
who do cannot afford to recharge the
battery or their phones so there are
many issues with getting vaccinated
india supreme court is hearing a plea to
prioritize vaccinations for the homeless
it has asked the authorities for details
about what is being done to protect them
from the virus these people who are
actually
the
last segment of the society no one is
actually concerned or bothered about
them about their vaccination i mean if
they are not vaccinated they will become
unintentional carriers also
even if access improves many like sony
are reluctant to get a shot
people have died because of the vaccine
so we will not get the vaccine and if we
get the shot who will take care of our
kids
the pandemic has already exposed the
socioeconomic inequities in india
now the fact millions of homeless people
are not being vaccinated is threatening
to hamper the fight against coronavirus
pavnei mithal al-jazeera new delhi